I love chocolate like chocolate makes me
happy man and gets me through some
stressful days it's sweet it just brings
joy to my life what's there not to like
about chocolate just thinking about
chocolate is making my mouth water and
it's making my heart happy because
chocolate has always been a reward it's
always been an indulgence chocolate is
the purest joy in the world next to dogs
and cats I think a hundred percent
dark chocolate is gonna be mind-blowing
ly amazing super sweet here are its dark
chocolate it's gonna be the best yeah so
we are here at Tosh in the Lower East
Side of New York City and we are going
to learn all about chocolate and
eventually try 100% pure chocolate so
did he tell us a little bit about Tosh
sure so Tosh means spot or smudge in
French because every time I'm wearing my
chef coat or my apron I usually it was a
smudge of chocolate on it somewhere so
for you believe with a smudge of
chocolate on you actually you don't have
a friend so hopefully it'll be in your
mouth so I do from a variety of
chocolate a white chocolate Ton Ton Ton
not real chocolate guys yeah white
chocolate is made up local butter milk
solids and sugar so it contains
absolutely no cacao my mind is blown
right now so this is a real chocolate
let's go up the scale so let's try some
milk chocolate mmm
loving it this is what heaven is like
the main differences between milk and
dark milk chocolate contains a time more
milk in it and it also contains some
cocoa mass some vanilla to give it a
little bit of flavor and some cocoa
butter it says it's only 35% chocolate
so it can only get better from here
so the next one that you guys are trying
is an 81% dark chocolate I think you'll
be able to taste more of the nuances in
it this is a different level this is
sort of like there's a bitterness to
this it's just like blowing my mind
today's pure chocolate it's like a
really spiritual at where a tea we have
a Nirvana know obviously 100 percent
chocolate is one of chocolate what what
is what does that mean so a hundred
percent chocolate comes with no frills
attached so it is just or an organic
chocolate mat basically they take cacao
beans and they ground them up nice and
fine and then they form it into a nice
little break that looks like that when
we get it we just chip away at it and
put it into our double boiler over there
and melt it and make it into wonderful
concoctions I like that all right I
think that looks great let's get ready
for these silky mouth feels your
chocolate definitely both whoa man
better is just it that is like the best
way to describe this I don't know kind
of like the taste of tobacco or like a
cigar so this is like literally day and
night I mean not just me soft like how
it looks but definitely by the way it
tastes this is like a little kid where
their parents give them wine and they're
like oh no this is supposed to taste
good but it doesn't it's an acquired
taste I guess I was naive and not
knowing what the taste of chocolate was
because the chocolate we know is mixed
with vanilla and cocoa butter and sugar
and all these great things
it just shows just how brilliant the
chocolate tears of the world are having
the more pure chocolate made me realize
I'm a basic chocolate lover and that's
okay I'm going to ask you to rest a
little piece of chocolate in between
your tongue and the roof of your mouth
and kind of swish it around your palate
like you would do with fine wine what
we're getting fancy as hell